תחום אחד שבו מחשוב קוונטי עשוי לשפר למידת מכונה
קשור לפונקציות גרעין או
מטריצות גרעין, בוא נחקור מה הן
ולמה אנחנו צריכים אותן. לשם כך נזכיר לעצמנו
שלושה דברים: למה מכפלות פנימיות מופיעות בלמידת מכונה?
למה בעיות למידת מכונה כוללות מימדים גבוהים יותר?
ומה הן פונקציות גרעין?
תזכור שהמכפלה הפנימית של
וקטורים ממשיים n-מימדיים a
ו-b נתונה על ידי מכפלת הגודל של a
בגודל של b וקוסינוס הזווית בין שניהם
זה שקול להכפלת כל רכיב של a ברכיב המתאים של
b ולסכום אותם. שים לב שאם הוקטורים
כמעט אורתוגונליים, כמו כשל-a
יש רכיבים אפסיים שם ל-b יש רכיבים גדולים
המכפלה הפנימית קטנה. זה שקול ל-
הזווית שמתקרבת לפאי חלקי שתיים
באופן דומה, אם ל-a יש רכיבים שליליים ול-b
יש רכיבים חיוביים
כלומר הוקטורים מצביעים
כמעט בכיוונים מנוגדים
והזווית קרובה לפאי
תוצאת המכפלה הפנימית יכולה להיות
שלילית. לבסוף, אם ל-a יש רכיבים גדולים שגם ל-b
יש רכיבים גדולים מאותו סימן
כלומר הוקטורים כמעט מקבילים והזווית קרובה לאפס
המכפלה הפנימית תהיה גדולה
וחיובית. אז סביר מאוד לצפות שמכפלות פנימיות
יהיו מדד שימושי לדמיון
בין נקודות נתונים. לא כל הנתונים n-מימדיים
ניתנים להפרדה בקלות ב-n פחות
ממד אחד, כלומר בקו
מישור או היפר-מישור. כשהנתונים לא מופרדים היטב
ב-n מימדים, אפשר לשבץ את נקודות הנתונים
במימדים גבוהים יותר, נגיד m מימדים שבהם m
גדול מ-n. זה נקרא מיפוי מאפיינים
שמסומן לרוב כ-x הולך לפי(x), שבו
פי(x) הוא מיפוי ממספרים ממשיים n-מימדיים ל-
מספרים ממשיים m-מימדיים
הכי קל לדמיין את זה כשמכופפים קבוצת נתונים חד-מימדית
למעלה לתוך
שני מימדים, או לוקחים נתונים דו-מימדיים
ומשבצים אותם בשלושה מימדים
אבל במציאות אנחנו לרוב משבצים נתונים במרחבים עם אלפים
ואפילו מיליוני מימדים
מכפלה פנימית של וקטורים תלת-מימדיים לעומת מכפלה פנימית
של וקטורים דו-מימדיים היא הבדל לא משמעותי
אבל מכפלה פנימית של וקטורים עם מיליון מימדים
הופכת ללא ניתנת לביצוע לחלוטין
כשמיישמים אותה על מערך נתונים גדול
אז אנשים חשבו על טריק חכם
מה אם היית משתמש בהטלה
למימדים גבוהים יותר שיש לה צורה מאוד ספציפית
כזו שהמכפלות הפנימיות של הוקטורים במימדים
הגבוהים יותר הן פונקציה פשוטה של
הוקטורים ממימדים נמוכים יותר? כלומר, מוצאים מיפוי
מהנתונים שלנו x לפי(x) ממימדים גבוהים יותר
כך שהמכפלה הפנימית ב-
מרחב המאפיינים נתונה על ידי
מרחב המאפיינים, נתונה על ידי
פונקציה פשוטה בנתונים ממימדים נמוכים יותר.
פונקציה k הזאת נקראת פונקציית גרעין
באופן אידיאלי היינו רוצים שפונקציית הגרעין הזאת
תהיה פונקציה של המכפלה הפנימית
ממימדים נמוכים יותר עצמה. זה ייתן לנו את
הטוב משני העולמות: מרחב מאפיינים בממדים גבוהים מאוד
אבל עם מכפלה פנימית זולה וקלה לחישוב
במבט ראשון זה אולי לא
ברור שזה בכלל אפשרי. בוא נסתכל על
דוגמה פשוטה אחת במימדים נמוכים מאוד
ניקח את מיפוי המאפיינים הספציפי הזה שממפה
וקטור תלת-מימדי ל-
מרחב תשע-מימדי. מסתבר
שהמכפלה הפנימית של מרחב המאפיינים התשע-מימדי הממופה
פשוט נתונה על ידי המכפלה הפנימית במרחב המקורי
התלת-מימדי בריבוע. כך שהמכפלה הפנימית
של המרחב הממופה תוך שימוש בפונקציות פי
תדרוש חישוב של כל אחד מ-
תשעת הקואורדינטות של
הוקטור הראשון ותשע עבור
השני, ואז המכפלה הפנימית עצמה שהיא
עוד תשע מכפלות וסכום
זה סך הכל עשרים ושמונה פעולות
פונקציית הגרעין דורשת שלוש מכפלות
ושני סכומים, שמתאימים לארבע פעולות בלבד
זה היה עבור מיפוי נקודת נתונים תלת-מימדית ל-
מרחב מאפיינים תשע-מימדי
קל לראות שזה יכול להיות יתרון גדול
עבור מרחבים גדולים מאוד.
פונקציית הגרעין היא בדרך כלל פונקציה רציפה
שאפשר להפעיל על כל וקטור במערך הנתונים שלך
אבל אנחנו משתמשים בפונקציות גרעין על ידי לקיחת
זוגות של נקודות נתונים מהקבוצה שלנו
כארגומנטים. הפעלת פונקציית גרעין על
כל זוג נקודות נתונים בקבוצה
מניבה מטריצה סימטרית שנקראת מטריצת
הגרעין. סוג פונקציית הגרעין שתשתמש בה תלוי ב-
הבעיה שלך. אז לסיכום:
תיאור הדמיון בין וקטורים במערכי הנתונים שלנו
לרוב דורש מכפלות פנימיות. מכפלות פנימיות ב-
מרחב מאפיינים בממדים גבוהים מאוד הופכות יקרות
אז אנחנו משתמשים במיפויי מאפיינים שמתאימים
לפונקציות גרעין מיוחדות מסוימות
שהופכות את החישוב ליעיל יותר
אבל המגבלה הזאת לפונקציות גרעין מיוחדות
אכן מגבילה אילו סוגי מיפויים למרחב המאפיינים יכולים
להתבצע ביעילות. זה
עלול למנוע מאיתנו להפריד היטב את הנתונים שלנו
אם רק הייתה דרך אחרת...
כאן נכנס מחשוב קוונטי
מיפוי המאפיינים בממדים גבוהים מאוד שמתאים
לפונקציות גרעין יכול להתבצע
על מחשב קוונטי. ב-quantum kernel estimator
מטריצת הגרעין k מחושבת
ומשם ניתן להשתמש באלגוריתם למידת מכונה קלאסי כדי
להשיג זאת. נקודת נתונים אחת x1
נטענת וממופה, ואז
x2 נוספת נטענת
וממופה. מכיוון שהמכפלה הפנימית של שני מצבים קוונטיים
קשורה להסתברות המדידה
אנחנו יכולים להעריך את המכפלה הפנימית של שתי נקודות הנתונים הממופות
על ידי ביצוע מספיק מדידות של
ה-circuit שנוצר. כך ה-circuit שלנו
יכול לספר לנו על מכפלה פנימית
בכל מרחב בממדים גבוהים שה-circuit יכול לדמות
מבלי שנחשב קלאסית מכפלה פנימית או
פונקציית גרעין. יש הרבה דרכים
להתאמה אישית ולשיפור של השיטות האלה
ואכן תמיד מוצעות שיטות חדשות
ונבדקות. אנחנו מקווים שה-
סקירה הזאת עזרה לסגור את המסגרת של
יישום מחשוב קוונטי
לשיטות למידת מכונה
ובמיוחד אלה שכוללות גרעינים